[Music]
in emergency landing news emergency
landing oh it was like this but don't
crash at the end yeah this is the one
where the lady got sucked out huh yeah
dude the whole world was on a lady pilot
I heard about this I heard it yeah oh no
spoilers okay sorry bye Brad gray like
Broadway but cooler brought away
Broadway ran your home on a grey road
right what a hot lady pirate pirate you
Percy with this airplane was supposed to
be very safe very well compare their
amount of crashes that happen with many
pilots then boy well above statistic
okay an exploding engine on the
southwest flight left a disturbing scene
for passengers so everyone but Nicky has
heard about this I'll just be exciting
for me where you being under a rock I
barely heard about this and I heard
there's a video 203 video I'm not sure
you do
Thanks someone just tear out their phone
he was getting out of a plane there's a
lot of people going Facebook live like
to a bunch of danda Wi-Fi was good up
there really should thank me well I
think it was getting closer to the
ground that Boingo I liked him so
anything yeah so I'm going to show you
any of the video because it's just I
mean you just see people just sad you
don't see anything
no II she died one passenger did die and
she was actually sucked out of the
window and people had to pull her back
in mid-flight I think that was good but
she died because she got sucked off it
was shrapnel that hit the window which
then that's a sucker out I don't know
exactly never I was sitting in a window
seat again was she wearing a soup oh I'm
assuming yes but obviously that wasn't
you know the back you miss you
no one wears a seatbelt - by the way
what are you talking about all the time
no they go being right and then the
minute goes I hear clicks go all the way
down the road I just leave it on cuz
it's like I know if I don't need to on
the back but on for 15 hours when you
bought it is good on Eve so do you
loosen it up yeah I take that [ __ ] off
immediately when I wouldn't like I know
we're up in the air and say I take that
[ __ ] off I haven't I'm biting my pants
inside why is it uncomfortable he
doesn't take it off I do I don't want my
ballsack sweating a SIBO makes your boss
anything I just go hot that's your own
issue of your legs and your balls will
never be hot again this is some final
destination [ __ ] dunno like fate itself
as a girl [ __ ] this [ __ ] in particular
and just kill the [ __ ] out of her
because it's too broke this mother in
particular and kill - what the fates a
bit I hope I never see you again
Thanks that's why you should never say
that to your parents like oh thanks let
me correct my [ __ ] statement I rather
have like half the airplane died or none
of them died because most would be the
only one dead you know to be like making
fun of early look at it she sacrificed
her life for the rest of us she did not
she didn't stand up there be like you
know what I will get sucked out I will
do that today know what she when she got
sucked out and everyone's pulling her in
did she get cut in half of people he
pulled her upper body in oh I'm trying
to figure out what part got stuck
because what if it sucked her in like
like like sandwich mode like her what
was sticking out like this oh [ __ ]
her intestines got son are you touching
your toes without bending your knees oh
you're almost there yeah I can't touch
my toes that's okay so this is a ongoing
journey for you yeah we try to win I
can't wait to get the Vegas together you
way we were doing she was following
jamali and yoga yeah I'm the Damali in
yoga because I made it up it's yoga with
knives and weapons in between your legs
okay so anyway this flight left New
York's LaGuardia Airport at 10:27 a.m.
and it was bound for Dallas but it had
it was forced to make an emergency
landing in Philadelphia at 11:23 watch
bias yeah and so what happened was the
left engine broke midair and then it
sent shrapnel toward the plane which
then hit that one particular window seat
because just like that one one person
that got [ __ ] over and everyone else
is like oh my god and it's just one
person and then everyone's like yeah it
is that one family that one family
saddest [ __ ] like why didn't you guys
die too
you're not part of this family sub worse
in depth on everyone I feel bad because
everyone's celebrating like oh thank God
we were alive it's like shut the [ __ ] up
dude don't rub it in the face of the
family it's the statement where they're
like oh my god we always lived except
for that one but that I doubt they're
celebrating and jumping for joy no you
know they said got it so well that
wasn't me yeah whispered it like to be
respectful I'm pretty sure like in war
you have your group of friends and one
of your friends catch a stray bullet
you're like thank God it wasn't me that
sucks bro like I would never say that if
we all of us were in a group you get
shot I wouldn't be like thank God it
wasn't me I'd be like that is so [ __ ]
up my that's not me how would you ever
say I wish you was me I probably would
if it was you guys oh no maybe not you
are you got a kid no you wouldn't wish
it was you everyone has that group of
friends that they would always stick up
for and like hope like I would go at the
end the world do it's not you [ __ ]
but you know eventually like I'll find
someone yeah [ __ ] up they're saying
that one of the blades from the fan
broke off so this is like 18 year old
dude that is final destination like I
could see it all being played out oh can
you imagine
you see that jet like on fire and [ __ ]
that's a seat I always take - it's
always on the wings yeah because there's
more space sir than me and it's the best
Instagram shot no it's the worst the
wings in the way no one to record you
want to eat the wing you get composition
there's a foreground element you know
machines go up and down when it's about
to landing I get so freaked out by that
I'm like it's broken
sometimes I see shows like duct tape on
him like that's normal that's fine I'm
fine
oh my god okay let's memorize those
seats guys dude that's the end of your
life is like falling from a passenger
plane and getting sucked out of a window
hey that's pretty yes yeah I think I'm
just saying if she had paid for
first-class show and boy down you're
like this is genius
no I'm just saying if she had just paid
for first-class she wouldn't have been
sitting down because they fly
first-class off in Southwest what it's
so they don't have first-class right
that'd be that blade flew all the way
back though that wing is the engine is
next to first-class but somehow flew all
the way back that really sucks this
experience I know you see once you see a
face you [ __ ] you don't know she
might have [ __ ] touch little kids we
don't know that she fit through a window
she tested the heat oh there that's true
heart shape as an angel oh what a
respect so the people couldn't pull her
back can you imagine being that person
that tried and then they like no she got
back in but yeah but yeah it was
shrapnel got her so she didn't fall in
época Oh
they'd like it vixx just partially out
of the gun got that but then like half
of her it's alright legs are flailing in
the air what part of the body
I really wonder like how exactly should
I did she die because the pressure
getting sucked out and you suck a finger
I imagine it was retract norm
but that was the reason like [ __ ]
window is this small can you imagine
being sucked out like that you're not an
octopus how the [ __ ] are you gonna fit
through that hole so could have broken
her spine it might be small maybe she's
like five foot ninety pounds their
family salsa 41 years old a Wells Fargo
Bank executive yeah EDC what is that I
thought you took kids do you see yeah I
think it is a Wells Fargo they're good
yeah how do you explain to like you know
like when you date someone in the future
like yeah my mom passed away and she got
sucked out of an airplane window isn't
that an automatic [ __ ] story yeah
yeah but then what about a god or go
automatic [ __ ] I don't know
you get cuddles I'm so sorry that's what
sucks that's in post coital [ __ ] like I
couldn't watch videos of people like
dying like murdered and [ __ ] but like
the thing that really gets me is when
just random [ __ ] small things happen
that just kills people that just should
yeah like they take out the trash and in
like the trash bag cuts their leg and
they get that [ __ ] infection and they
die yeah that happened to my aunt's
friend when I was growing with a trash
bag no he worked at a pet store and he
cut himself on a rat cage just like a
little cut right he cleaned it out right
away and then it started getting like
kind of infected so he went to the
hospital and they're like no you're fine
just clean it just keep training it and
then he went again after it didn't get
better and they're like no no no it
should be fine just keep cleaning it and
then he had to be air air vac or where's
a girl airlifted the affection going to
his bloodstream yeah and then he died in
the hospital
oh my god it was a family man at the
hospital like they said it police he got
sent away how many times at hospital
I've heard that so many thing get sued
did they sue I don't I don't think so
yeah I can't see usually felt like I saw
a video of a do this like he stepped
outside for a cigarette and then the
card is barreled into him and killed him
like I can walk the face of planet leash
I think that's good motivation for not
smoking
I like watching [ __ ] like that because
it
mine's you how like delicate life yeah
I'm not scared to just go out and do
things enjoy your life I'm so freaked
out that's the worst way to die as some
freak accident I like to think that I'm
invincible
should we get some praise to the this
pilot though yeah captain
Tammy Joe Schultz a former fighter pilot
hell yeah go girl
oh she was a fighter pilot doesn't
matter pilot what are you like a teen
whatever she [ __ ] made a safe landing
because of that it was like really calm
throughout the whole thing why does she
look like dr. Quinn Medicine Woman
that's so cool I bet her life is so
[ __ ] dumb was a man who looked at the
[ __ ] engine before takeoff and he did
a thorough job now you're broke you try
to jump back on our side cuz you heard
she did a great job
what a douchebag he was doing man things
like he was supposed to fix something
baby scratched his balls instead he drop
the [ __ ] bolts and [ __ ] and then he
didn't laugh but it will [ __ ] fly out
so I thought to honest bone he was like
I'm a man I know what I'm doing these
[ __ ] are Polynesian man to why I
always see Polynesian do is working on
planes oh that's true the toilets
apologies I think a Samoan mechanic or
something yeah just Samoan guy throwing
your luggage as hard as he can carry oh
dude it's so sad though I hope her
family's alright yeah that is sad
[Music]